donald trump was one of the worst things
ever happened to america
whoa whoa whoa
hot take hold hold on hold on hold hot
take oh
bingo baby actually kind of feels good
it's
[Laughter]
i'm not i'm not putting trump down trump
meant well
but if you really pull back the way he
radicalized the left the way he got
people
when they were sweating a lot did you
take a copy vaccine before you came here
no man i'm a fat [ __ ]
no here's okay this is good this room is
really hot it is hot
it is hot we keep it hot we keep it nice
and hot i don't know that's you buddy we
keep it hot we got to keep out those
lizards man this lizard
the lizard people there's logos that's
true oh they like it hot
uh oh are we outta ourselves okay but go
back so donald trump the way he did he
radicalized
well no here's the deal i've learned
about hegelian dialectics okay a lot of
glass in my hair it's a new thing
yeah it's like i'm a stripper now i have
like glitter all over me um
i'm actually a top stripper every
tuesday night in austin
no seriously here's the deal
there's a big populist movement against
globalism trump did win the election he
gets in
but then they're able to so panic the
left to get them to censor
and to get them to attack speech and to
get them to go out and do all these
horrible things that
now they basically escalated american
politics
uh to where people aren't even thinking
about the actual issues anymore it's
become so tribal and it wasn't donald
trump that did it it was the media
that that basically built him into this
demon and then used that symbol
to get all their people on board to
doing things that liberals would never
say get rid of free speech
i mean i remember the aclu would say i
don't agree with the kkk but we're going
to sue this town that will let him march
let him march they get laughed at yelled
at
now they like banned them from marching
now they ban everybody for marching
and it's very dangerous because who
decides who can do that who decides you
can
what you're saying is in the same way
that you ban a book and then make it a
bestseller
that's what liberals are doing by
banning so many people you're just
making them you know that's part of it
but
but but they also use the hatred of
trump to get
liberals to go against the very
foundation of liberal philosophy
that's what you said about it okay
gotcha right isn't that crazy by the way
schultz that's how you're a lovable
likable guy so are you guys
you sell your male fans out there i mean
that's why they
they can't sell censoring getting rid of
you
because they know you're one of the top
comics out there i mean everything you
do gets like three four five million ten
million views
so whether you like to admit it you're
not the reason just dave chappelle and
joe rogan are talking about you is
because you're obviously gonna be one of
the top comedians in the country in the
world you already are
so you're like hey you're like when did
you realize how big you are we all need
to realize how big we are every voice is
powerful but yours is really big
and so that's why that's why you've been
somewhat left alone is because they can
see you're innocent
and you're successful and and if you
turn against them they've got a problem
just like joe rogan
another great point you made joe rogan
i'm not gonna tell the inside baseball
but youtube really messed with him
he's this nice guy he tried to work with
him they used him working with him
like giving him attention having guests
on being friendly to even dominating
more
so he went made a new deal to go over
there they tried to censor him he was
cool about it
inside beat him defeated him came back
out has total control of the show
but he had to go through hell to do that
and now you get to see the real joe
rogan
who everybody loves even more who's more
populist more courage great guess
kicking ass but he was like more of a
cerebral guy than me i just attack like
king kong when i get [ __ ]
joe rogan like you jiu jitsu them
[ __ ] yeah
uh yeah i guess the words judo used
their own attacks on him
yeah that's why joe was like oh i'm dumb
no he's a smart [ __ ]
oh yes anybody who says they're dumb
yeah
he's a smart mother probably a hundred
percent so yeah so i mean that's where
it comes from is that
joe loves everybody like super it's not
like a fake thing with him he loves
everybody
he's like why don't we all just come
together why don't we all just he's
literally
a good guy that got immense power
without even wanting it
it's not like his goal is like i'm gonna
be the most powerful voice in media
no they just kept [ __ ] with it i know
they kept [ __ ] pushing the top and
it was so funny he hit me once he was
like dude every time one of these like
hit pieces comes out of me
my numbers skyrocket it's like they
don't even realize that no no no no
more more attack pieces please that's
the thing is joe joe's so nice he would
project himself onto things i know him
like 23 years now
he would project himself you know alex
people aren't that mean they're not that
bad now he's like past me
yeah like where he he's like all he does
is research now he knows everything
yeah he's so it's it's definitely an
exciting situation he's the best because
if you can
you know it's not like i told joe rogan
what to think he just saw himself
yeah yeah you're like look at this stuff
i wonder if they i wonder if like uh
those people that like reach out to you
these people that reach out to different
folks like
i wonder if they understand who they can
and can't influence like
i doubt anybody reached out to joe and
was like we'd like to control you now
i i bet they're like yeah we're not
gonna be able to control this guy we
just gotta try to like radicalize him
or no they just do stuff like like oh hi
the youtube president wants to talk to
you
joe didn't tell me this i've got these
calls like 10 years ago but then i
talked to job i'm going to give anything
away but it's like
why don't you just try to work with
these guidelines come on be a team
player
and you're like and then the minute you
halfway give them they get even worse
just like it's like being controlled by
a pimp or something and it's just like
joe's like [ __ ] this man i mean i'm not
gonna say what he's told me probably he
talks to you even more than me but
i know he loves you but the point is is
like you get that thing as a man where
you're like man you're not gonna [ __ ]
enslave me you're not gonna
tell me what i'm gonna [ __ ] do to
certain but then joe's smart about it
he's been more like but i mean here's
the deal new world order you radicalize
joel rogan you keep [ __ ] pushing man
you don't [ __ ] stop leave us the [ __ ]
alone
they radicalized me i speak anti george
bush and i still am
antoine wore everything they call me a
right-wing [ __ ] nazi yeah
been [ __ ] arrested twice by george w
bush not a [ __ ] right winger
yeah but they they don't stop man they
just lie
and lie and attack them attack and they
make you get in the position
of saying okay i'm a [ __ ] man up i'm
way [ __ ] smarter than you and i'm
more popular to you and now i'm going to
run your ass over
let's go [ __ ] go and you know what
and here's the thing and this is how you
know it works it works right
i'm 37 akash 37.
mark this is the next generation of
comedian mark is 24 years old 24 years
old
okay i i can't speak for you but i
imagine
you're like i have to create my own
thing
i imagine you're not going i need to
audition and see what the next show on
showtime is or comedy center or anything
i have to create my own thing and maybe
i will do deals with comedy central
netflix or these things but
i have to create my own thing obviously
mark is integral
in this whole process and building
everything that we've built here he
co-wrote the netflix special so i mean
but the point is like
the influence of rogan the influence of
all the guys you the guys who have gone
independent and built careers
is starting to take place in the next
generation the next generation is not
going how do i get on cnn
they're not going how do i get on comedy
central they're going i want my
own [ __ ] [ __ ] and you just said it
that's why you're better than i am at
this exactly you just crystallized it
everyone gets it now that it's about
being your own person
he's not thinking let somebody call me
and tell me what to do some old [ __ ]
man
some old white man what about white
people bunch of old [ __ ] white people
[ __ ] you man
i'm not going to listen to you dude and
so and so that's the deal is that is
that he's doing his own deal
that's going to give him pleasure in
doing his own deal and seeing that
successful yeah that's why these guys
can't control us
so they think oh i'll just scare this
guy i'll scare that guy i'll mess with
joe rogan and tell him what he can say
all he does is create a whole new deal
and get ten times more radical yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah what do you think
most powerful do you think that that's
something that is specific to you or do
you think other comics
your age are also taking that same
approach no i think it's generational
that
everyone not even comics but i just
think all content creators
like the the rise of like youtube and
all these other like platforms is
like democratized content creators and
they're seeing the
like the further generation they go yeah
i'll just do that and that's
that's i think it's taking shape it's
not about what old man you gotta go kiss
their ass
and who it's like it's like hey people
want it they're gonna buy it bro
it used to drive me nuts i would go to
these these comedy festivals and i would
see comics like
kissing these executives asking oh god
they would [ __ ] disgust me
and i was like i just can't do it i
cannot do it there's got to be another
[ __ ] way
you